bonjour je fais cette petite vidéo assez
rapide pour vous donner quelques infos
sur ce qui se passe en ce moment sur la
chaîne donc la première chose dont je
voulais vous parler c'est que depuis un
mois à peu près je ne suis créé un
compte sur your type
alors vous en avez peut-être déjà
entendu parler parce que d'autres
vidéastes ont fait la même chose et
c'est super parce que le principe c'est
que vous pouvez et de nous aider à nous
financer grâce à nos vidéos sans payer
le principe c'est vous pouvez regarder
jusqu'à cinq pubs par jour qui dure 30
secondes et ça rapporte 10 centimes pour
chaque pub regardez donc en gros vous
pouvez nous apporter 50 centimes par
jour moi c'est ce que je fais je me
regarde mais plus que tout les jours et
je regardais pub d'autres vidéaste et
c'est super parce que bon c'est un
système qui marche qui
beaucoup plus efficace que la
monétisation de youtube par exemple et
c'est sûr fin on récupère l'argent c'est
pas une arnaque
donc c'est trop bien et d'ailleurs si
vous même avez un goût type vous qui me
regarde et vous pouvez aussi y mettre le
lien dans la description parce que je
type aussi des autres vidéaste que
j'aime
donc j'ai pas le temps de faire pour
tout le monde tous les jours parce que
même si on met la vidéo en fond et qu'on
fait autre chose en même temps il faut
déjà y penser mais bon j'essaye de type
est aussi les gens que j'aime
régulièrement donc voilà ça c'est un
nouveau moyen de financement que je vous
mets dans la description parce qu'on ne
peut pas l'afficher comme tipi à la fin
de la vidéo
j'ai aussi un tipi d'ailleurs ça je
pense que vous savez toute façon mais
dont q-tip c'est un nouveau moyen de
financement ou là vous n'avez rien à
payer vous même c'est l'argent de la
publicité qui nous revient ensuite j'ai
les cheveux rouges vous avez remarqué
ouais en fait ils sont pas si rouge mais
là je suis en plein dans rayon de
lumière donc ils sont très rouge mais
c'est cool
et sinon je voulais voir merci aussi
pour les réactions à mon blog sur mon
voyage à tromsoe ou
beaucoup de gens ont été émus
apparemment par mon témoignage
donc je vais bien vous inquiétez pas
parce qu'ils ont dit que j'avais l'air
d'avoir les larmes aux yeux et toujours
c'est sûr j'étais déçu mais ça va et j'y
retournerai c'est tout et si ça mais si
jamais ça vous intéresse lac cette
question d or qu'est-ce qu'ils sont
apparus
oui la semaine après mon retour il ya eu
plein d'or qu ils ont vu désordre des
baleines une mère corps que quel était
son petit et depuis ils envoient
régulièrement les orques sont rentrés
dans le fjord donc bonne nouvelle ça se
passe très bien en ce moment là bas pour
sinon aussi bien évidemment je continue
les vidéos j'ai eu du mal à écrire celle
de décembre mais elle est écrit de
saillé et donc je vais sûrement la
tournée la semaine prochaine et il y
aura au moins une autre vidéo qui
sortira en décembre toujours de
l'histoire de toute manière sur un autre
projet et dernière petite info si vous
l'avez raté j'ai participé aussi à la
vidéo d'une autre chaîne qui s'appelle
donc la chaîne ses sweats berry et elle
parle de comptes et de symbolique
principalement dans le cinéma
donc là elle a fait une vidéo sur la
symbolique du scorpion et comme je suis
scorpions on est parti dans un petit
délire de courts métrages dedans donc
j'apparais aussi dans sa vidéo il a je
vous mets le lien à la fin parce que sa
chaîne et bien abonnez vous et voilà
c'était tout ce que je voulais vous dire
je vous souhaite une bonne journée et
donc la prochaine vidéo si tout va bien
normalement sortira le 1er mercredi 2
décembre à 16h30
ce qui nous amène je pense au 6 décembre
mais peut-être que je me trompe et
peut-être aussi que j'aurai du retard
mais je pense pas ça devrait aller
voilà et bien bonne journée à tous et
merci d'avoir regardé et je vous laisse
si vous voulez aller voir les liens qui
seront dans la description pour your
type principalement et pour la chaîne
dessous de berry voilà merci